okay why'd you let hear about that
winning a roadie oh my gosh is that a
thing you've ever experienced yes oh my
gosh I feel like we were speaking about
the wrong manly man when maneet was on
how many rodeos have you won you're
having to think so hard maybe 40 what
that manly man left he fell intimidated
I think it's got the biggest applause of
the night like yeah jokes are fine this
guy want 40 rodeos this is where I'm
gonna show my ignorance that means you
killed the bull right now okay so
winning a rodeo that is a great
suggestion and if you are in this kind
of segment of people what you want to
hear about that
a beauty pageant in Minnesota um I don't
know the stereotype in Minnesota are
people they're ugly is that why that's
funny now are you from Minnesota no okay
I see you're very pretty that makes
sense then okay so beauty pageants in
Minnesota and winning rodeos so far guys
these are quite good suggestions so the
next three suggestions don't let me down
I'm gonna come to the front row the
person you with ducked out being like
I'm too intimidated to come up with a
suggestion but don't worry does this
other people who can help what you want
to rap about medical debt oh my gosh way
to bring the mood right down may I
inquire do you yourself have problems in
medical debt no not right no right now
Wow optimism real optimism just like not
right now but Chris we're all we're all
gonna die right we're all okay medical
debt beauty pageant in Minnesota winning
a rodeo or winning 40 ratios let's come
to you guys over here what you want to
hear about white privilege do oh yeah
that's that's a great suggestion I mean
it's really again spoiled the mood a lot
but I like that I'm not
I'm down with that and let some come to
the back of the room what would you guys
like this is the last suggestion so make
it good okay
cool that sounds like it came from
experience right yeah and that was that
beat you went on a date and they invited
you to play basketball oh you suggested
it well
winner takes all that is a pretty crazy
I mean sex right that's what we're
talking about
it's like skateboarding horse but the
loser gets [ __ ] okay cool so I don't
play basketball by I know skating so
that's okay wait what's the you can play
horse in basketball though can't you
yeah okay cool
see I know about your country and
culture right those suggestions are
great to remind you the suggestions were
a beauty pageant in Minnesota medical
debt white privilege playing basketball
on your tinder day and winning rodeos
those are amazing suggestions guys and
as as a treat for you I'm gonna take
them and turn them into a flawless a
perfect a brilliant freeze people over
there laughing they don't think it's
gonna actually happen they think I'm
gonna put a mic in the stand and leave
no it's gonna happen it's gonna be a
freestyle made upon the spot not
rehearse not prepared don't worry you
won't be anywhere near as atrociously
bad as you're expecting a privately
educated middle-class white British boy
to be if we can drop the beat my friend
let's let's have some fun
[Music]
still summer flitter I'm gonna start in
this corner with you
I never travel far and wide I don't go
there looking at the hot ladies in
Minnesota not hot in the kind of temper
away because it's north of the border a
her today people in Minnesota behavior
so nice living near Canada yeah my
advice if you move from a later leave a
California see you can win a pageant
there cuz the ladies are let's breathe a
look see they're like maybe six hour ten
the hooker doesn't go her legs on them
Akana wobbly and horrible sure and
stumpy I touched one watch she was kind
of love deeper the wrong place not like
an hourglass it was like straight then
here and then no ass I was not impressed
but the size of her breasts are very
sorry this misogyny is hard to digest so
let me move on since I was a little kid
I benefited so much from white privilege
I never got stopped by the Popo they saw
me walking with a knife they were like
go free and I wandered around
trunk I was getting at my car I had weed
in the trunk but then they saw me there
and we're like now you're nice we like
you why because my skin was white all of
the privilege that I got paid more I
couldn't walk into a random house
through the back door when I was drunk
under owner who wouldn't call 9-1-1
wouldn't just assume my skin color means
I'm a felon they let me go
gave me a little cake it was really
nicely on a holiday I take down in Texas
check us I go in my guide I'm on the
back of house and they're kicking me
high but I never fall off because I've
got a great grip on the handle a whole
day yeah I never do slit it's a vaguely
like I'm in a sexual position
when I win rodeos I have an admission
because it gets me hard it gets me so
aroused which is from the cowboy acts
how is the crowd going this guy look at
him go he's got four old on the rodeo No
eles never kicked out the back of the
steer if you don't know how to do it
then you're a queer because people who
like that type of or usually have not
been liberally told anyway if it ends
badly don't forget you might break an
ankle and get the medical debt because
insurance cover cover activities if
you're uh a rodeo rider proclivity
they're like it's your fault you're the
one to blame
oh you now owe a hundred thousand in the
gutter
you'll die on the bed and even when
you're dead you'll still have the debt
we pass it on to your heirs of your
progeny they're like please get the
medicals they're off of me but they
can't get it they'll never be free wanna
go on a date with me and try and shoot
threes okay yeah I'm pleased to report
I'm seeking all of the baskets on that
cord I met up with the nice lady on
tinder
she was from Minnesota so I wish she was
thinner but it was okay I said play with
me we'll play basketball you'll lose
calories you'll get even thinner and
then you'll jump high I can dunk balls
quite well for a white guy there you go
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much for watching please
watch more replenish status subscribe
share like comment all those things
shouting bye
[Applause]